i mean because look look broadway you've
done a lot of theater you did ed you've
done movies
and now you're on flash and now you get
to play a bad guy
and then you get to play a bunch of
other characters dr wells who's like
different personalities right he's all
over the place he's in different
universes
this character so you could play sort of
nice and sort of like you just
do you like this stuff as much as you
like the broadway as much as you like
the straight drama
or is it just another thing that you're
you're experiencing um
i wouldn't grade it uh
in comparison in any way only because
that's this is not a politically correct
answer
and i think you understand why this is
because i i perceive from gratitude to
have
any job i really do it's not like that
is not like a blanket statement of like
you know because one of the things that
especially i think you and i know this
and i think it's it's lost on people
that have success at
21 and they'll they'll they'll get there
because how could you have any basis of
comparison
but the idea that you know proceeding
from gratitude for
the employment or the or the specific
job that you have is a huge thing
because i think a lot of people go well
michael
is just he's just dancing from this show
to that show to this movie to that play
to this kind of thing
and tom's doing the same and i think
what people miss is
the giant and capitalized letters will
they have you and most of the time they
won't
they want somebody better than me they
want somebody
has is more cachet they want they want
brad pitt they want
and that's a that's a that's kind of a
fanciful example you know it's like if
that's the way it is that's just the way
hollywood is you want
brad pitt but i'm trying to come up with
an example it's like if they're if they
can get me they're also kind of like
well maybe we could get matthew perry or
you know what i mean like there's
there's some other element that's kind
of close but
you know like is it better get for them
it's a better splash when they make an
announcement
and we run into that all the time and i
think
when i watch somebody who's not me like
you i think he's just going from
gate to gate or i look at you know movie
stars
um i look at i'm friends with uh
this isn't this is a name drop but he's
doing such great stuff right now john
krasinski
oh dude by the way i'm a huge horror fan
yeah huge and quiet place was just one
of the few that i really liked i mean i
don't like a lot of horror these days
and that was
really good the interesting thing about
that is one of one of the whole things
that when we talked about directing one
of the whole things
and one of the main things i try to do
is and it's it's obvious
because every director i think wants to
do this but you want to show and not
tell but that movie the whole that whole
the whole basis of that movie was show
don't tell because they're not
you can't talk right and so it's so
interesting right like oftentimes when
you're a young actor like
can you communicate what you're trying
what what's going on in this scene
without using words
and you should be able to do that by and
large but then of course we do
superhero shows where there's a massive
amount of writing about feelings and
people are so so there's so much
self-knowledge
we run into something like a quiet place
it can be jarring because
they did such a magnificent job these
characters were so rich
and so fulfilled and yet they didn't say
anything i would have died
i would have died in the first minute
not being able to say anything even if i
wasn't supposed to die i still would
have died rosenbaum you can't
talk well i i just i have to there's
like there's a meeting amongst the
producers at night like hey
so i know he survives to page 68 but we
were thinking get rid of him what if we
kill michael
now would that be cool like i know it's
a rewrite but we could do that
plus the other actress can't hear him
when they're acting he's like far away
he's not even he's whispering like he's
playing a superhero or something
i just don't get it what is he doing
there
this is what i do on my show but you
were there the answer to your question
is like you know i
i don't have um i know it seems pat but
it really is true i never
would have expected you know to be
putting on a
in the age of superhero to be one of the
people who gets to put on
the villain suit you know what i mean
that would never have been
you know when i started out
professionally i never thought and at
one point
you know i hope to play joker or you
know a reverse flash or something like
that and so
i have a i have a massive amount of
gratitude sure for that because you know
that could have gone to
a myriad of humans and i you know they
that
became one of those things like will
they have you they would have me for
that one and so
i think for most of the roles that you
get you're just like oh that's great i
got that i got this role
i remember on my first broadway
show i got i'm canadian i got cast out
of canada
i couldn't believe it i just i i i
couldn't believe it you know
was it you're in town no that was that
was that's awesome
no that was a play and i think it was
around the turn our boys was coming home
from war
like it was you know a national
nightmare was over and they
that was a show called shenandoah about
the um
about the civil war uh musical starring
how linden from barney miller fame
went on to uh went on to be uh voiced by
uh
the inimitable john cullum um
interesting enough john cullum and i i
did another broadway show years later
and john cullen was the lead of that one
too
um you know he's a
massive talent and you know
the interesting thing is about about
that is
when the the new york the broadway
producers came to
came under search through america and
then through canada
you know they the advantage i had was
they didn't know anybody so in the
echelon of
canadian actors i was at the very bottom
but they didn't know who the guys at the
top were either
so it was a brief moment in the audition
room it was a fair fight
um and you know i got that i got that
job and
the the gratitude for getting that job
going to to broadway you know you lay
heavy elation when they're like hey
guess what michael you're
you got the you got the roll and it's
like it lasts for a little bit and then
you get there and then there's obstacles
to overcome and you're like this guy's
an
idiot and or there's you know something
doesn't go well and you're like it all
plunges away like i remember
playing basketball and going i just want
to make the team and then
after you make the team that's all you
wanted you just want to be part of the
team and after a while it's like well i
want to play and after you when i want
to start
afterwards i want to get my point you
know like it's just that michael jordan
if you have a competitive nature or
what's interesting about that broadway
thing and i know i'm talking about
myself way too much no
this is why i want you to the
interesting thing about that broadway
thing is that elation
lasted it's still there
you